i don't remember which
record this was conway because i
listened to so many songs last night
um but when we talk about you
speaking about your demons and your
experiences and [ __ ]
you were talking about your drinking
problem
right right on cue as i'm taking a sip
[Laughter]
and now i mean look at the end of the
day like we all got our [ __ ] demons
right like
you know what i'm saying like do you do
you consider yourself someone who's like
an alcoholic at all
um yes yes i'm uh
i consider myself an alcoholic you know
what i'm saying
functioning of course yeah yeah yeah
i mean like i don't know i feel like
it's levels to that word like you know
what i'm saying like i ain't
i've seen some alcoholics that are just
turning them like bombs
right right you know i know why no
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying but i do
you know i enjoy a nice cocktail with
dinner you know what i'm saying i'm
recording i'm in the store
i'm definitely going let me back out a
bottle of deuces something
you know what i'm saying has that how
you always have been or was that
something because obviously like you
said man like
you got shot you come out of the
hospital
you i can only imagine how hard it is to
like
like you said like you being able to
talk about it in your music
it helps you like feel free and [ __ ] but
i can imagine
you know going through some [ __ ] like
that that's gotta be like like
you got it like like you said depression
is involved like
did you resort to like alcohol to help
you get through some of that [ __ ]
yeah i'm gonna be honest um you know
what i'm saying i used to
i used to like i said i uh
like for me like i would be drinking
this [ __ ] to try to like
so i can keep [ __ ] off my mind not be
thinking about the [ __ ] that i'll be
depressed about it like a lot of things
that
you know i've been going through over
the last couple of years you know what
i'm saying
so i just like like hide behind a bottle
kind of
mm-hmm what i'm saying but i've been
able to
you know i'm saying the best thing you
could do is just face it you know what
i'm saying
head on like sometimes you just gotta
look
look [ __ ] look your demons in the eyes
and like you know what i'm saying that's
how you get
get past them [ __ ] get over them [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying that
so i you know i definitely
uh you know i mean gravitated to the to
the liquor and [ __ ] a little more than
usual
you know what i'm saying because it was
like i just didn't want to think about
i just wanted to forget everything and
just
you know man like just have fun just be
a fun
like because it's funny like you know
what i'm saying like a lot of people
like if they don't know me or that never
been around me
they'd be thinking like like i'm like
i'm screwed facing them or i'm like
you know yeah yeah they'd be looking at
you crazy if they don't know your story
or
yeah they think yeah i'm just like i'm
on [ __ ] like i'm just this big
this mean you know what i'm saying bad
dude so
i try to like you know i'm saying drink
and joke around and stuff kind of like
to
you know what i'm saying to to you know
lighten the mood
so to speak but like i said like behind
closed doors and [ __ ] like
you know man it's a lot man personally
it's a lot professionally
is something now that you're kind of
known for and i and on one of the
records that i heard last night you
would say like i wonder if
essentially if you never got shot and
never had uh
the bell's palsy would there still be
murals of you
on walls right and all that [ __ ] yeah so
it's like
obviously it's a personal you know
situation that you're dealing with but
but i think you you also recognize that
like
it's a part of your hip-hop character
now
you know what i'm saying yeah absolutely
i definitely
accept it and and and and wear it
you know i'm saying more prideful like
more
you know what i'm saying more
comfortable with it you know what i'm
saying the bell's palsy and [ __ ] and i
do realize
i feel like everything that comes from
god is a blessing you know what i'm
saying
so god don't make mistakes god don't
make mistakes so this was
i feel like maybe this was the blessing
that i needed because like
around the time like when i got shot
like i was i was um
i was moving different i really wasn't
taking music serious
you know what i'm saying like we was
outside you know what i'm saying so
i feel like you know i mean sometimes i
think about it like that like damn i
feel like god just
did that i mean like like almost almost
like
as a signal like look man like this you
got so much you got you so gifted and
you got so much
potential and so much ahead of you but
you ain't taking this [ __ ] serious so
you know what
i'm i'm gonna you know what i mean
what's life like that it's crazy too
because you
probably your your verse that
you're most famous for the cow right
yeah that specific record when you talk
about your boy getting shot
right and how it was almost like a
blessing that you didn't
know who did it because you could have
went in you would have obviously
wouldn't have gotten revenge
i would have yeah and you wouldn't have
been sitting here
right right because i mean or you might
have been but yeah you know what i'm
saying
it's almost like you said like god don't
make mistakes like yo like
like you're in this position now you now
they gotta mention you top five you know
what i'm saying right
right right you know i mean things could
have went a lot definitely
and been a lot worse so that was another
thing that helped me kind of overcome
like
you know be on some [ __ ] like man what
i'm tripping for like i'm still alive
you know what i'm saying i'm still you
know i'm gonna go money i can still rap
i can still talk i can still walk
i can still [ __ ] you [ __ ] yo for sure